welcome to the Macmillan report I'm
Marilyn Wilkes your host and today our
guest is Professor Ben Kiernan our topic
is genocide professor Kernan is the a
Whitney Griswold professor of history at
Yale University and the founding
director of Yale's genocide studies
program for more than 30 years he has
studied and written about genocide and
crimes against humanity
his recent book blood and soil a world
history of genocide and extermination
from Sparta to Darfur is the first
global history of genocide and in it
professor Kernan examines outbreaks of
mass violence from the Classical era to
the present
welcome professor Kernan thanks Marilyn
let's begin by talking about the word
genocide it's a relatively recent term
how would you define it well it was
coined only during World War two by
Raphael Lemkin who was a Polish Jewish
jurist who'd spoken out against the
Armenian Genocide in World War one and
then wrote a book during World War two
about the Nazi occupation and the crimes
they were committing and in that book he
coined the term genocide in 1943 and he
was the major proponent of the Genocide
Convention which was adopted by the UN
in 1948 and came into force in 1950 so
it was his conception of genocide that
became the definition under
international law and the definition in
the convention of 1948 says that
genocide is acts committed with the
intent to destroy in whole or in part a
national ethnical racial or religious
group as such and these acts include
killing members of the group in other
forms of mass violence and that was
pretty much his definition except that
he probably would have preferred
political groups as well as ethnic and
religious and national groups to be
covered by the Genocide Convention
although they are
covered by crimes against humanity the
particular crime of extermination when
it systematically carried out covers the
mass murder of political groups he
probably would have also wanted cultural
destruction to be included in the
convention but that was not either
however other people do define genocide
in different ways sociologically many
people think that mass murder of
political groups is pretty much the same
as of ethnic or religious groups and so
there are disagreements in the scholarly
literature but I'm fairly convinced that
the legal definition is usable and
functional and that other crimes which
are not included as genocide for
instance included as extermination under
crimes against humanity okay clearly
genocide is a difficult topic yet you've
devoted the majority of your career to
researching it and writing about it how
did you come to study it well I was
educated in Australia and I was aware of
some of the history of what had happened
to aboriginal groups during the colonial
conquest of Australia in the nineteenth
century but my first overseas experience
was actually in East Timor near to
Australia now an independent country in
Southeast Asia but then a Portuguese
colony later to be invaded by Indonesia
in 1975 and I studied Southeast Asian
history in Australia and also became
very interested in what was happening in
Vietnam during the war there and in
Cambodia and after the war in Cambodia
the Khmer Rouge regime of Pol Pot took
power and at the same time as the
Indonesians were invading and carrying
out extermination massacres in East
Timor the Khmer Rouge regime was doing
something on a larger scale although
proportionately similar in Cambodia and
as a result of
doing my PhD dissertation on the Khmer
Rouge history I then went on to write a
another study of what they did after
they took power under the Pol Pot regime
okay um over the course of history what
have you found to be the motivators for
genocide and have they changed over time
well it's difficult to always know for
sure what the specific motivations are
they're often hidden and they're usually
multiple although sometimes a single
motivation racial hatred stands out for
instance in the Holocaust where it's
arguable that the motivation behind
Hitler's mass murder of Jews really was
ethnic hatred although the word motive
is not mentioned in the Genocide
Convention and it covers cases where
genocide could be a means rather than a
motive and so for instance driving a
population away could be the motive and
committing genocide against part of a
group would be a means of conquering a
territory or carrying out ethnic
cleansing or it could be for the motive
of seizing their wealth genocide can be
a means as well as a motive there are
other factors that can be examined as
well not just the determining feature of
singling out ethnic or religious groups
for mass killing but also other features
that sometimes accompany or often
accompany or are associated with
genocide and over the centuries many of
these have recurred again and again not
just racial or religious hatred but also
territorial expansion ISM is something
that usually happens alongside genocide
of course it brings warfare to the front
for consideration of when genocide is
really happening and of course war often
gives genocides a cover or an excuse to
carry out genocide against an ethnic
group and that's usually in the context
of territorial expansion ISM another
couple of ideological features in the
mindset of perpetrators that recur
pretty much on and on through the
centuries are a fetish with antiquity a
concept of a pristine ancient people
usually farmers who have been somehow
contaminated or disturbed by foreign
settlers or invading pastoralists and in
the case of the Nazis or I would say the
Hutu chauvinist regime which committed
the genocide in Rwanda or in Cambodia
under the Khmer Rouge there is this
concept of an ancient past where the
ethnic population of Germans or Hutus or
chimere's we're living in pristine calm
but have since become invaded by
minorities whether it be Jews or Tutsis
or Vietnamese or other minorities in
Cambodia and those minorities become
targets for the exterminator E ideology
and practice of the regime so that
concept of an ancient model and also of
the agrarian paradise in some cases that
was supposedly in existence in the past
is also a an imaginary imaginative
feature of the ideology of genocide 'us
they tend to target city populations
rather than farmers although farmers can
also be caught up in the violence
because the perpetrators are usually
urban themselves but they romanticize
the rural landscape
rural occupations and the virtues
particularly as soldiers of farmers and
of course they sometimes target not just
city populations but other non farming
rural populations including cattle
raisers or other pastoralists or
hunter-gatherers whether it be the Tutsi
Patrick pastoralists in Rwanda or
Aboriginal groups in North America and
Australia who are considered to be
inadequate farmers of the land and that
feature often does accompany genocidal
ideology as well okay so what are some
of the key factors that you've found to
be precursors to genocide and are you
seeing any of these today
well territorial expansion is the
envisaging of extending territory
whether it is conquering again territory
that has been long lost to a neighboring
country in the past the the vision of
extending territorial power and what
should be done with the land is is an
important precursor that can be seen
sometimes in the advanced propaganda of
genocidal regimes as well as this
concept of the past that needs to be
restored lost territory goes along with
them and so militaristic states also can
be considered precursors of genocide I
would say that ancient Sparta which was
described by some historians as a
workshop of war was a precursor to later
genocide all regimes in classical
antiquity okay
let's talk specifically about two
regions of the world's Darfur and the
Congo and the genocide and mass killings
that are taking place there what do you
think it will take to have it stopped
well I think four has received much less
attention than it deserves as an ongoing
case of genocide which could be
restrained at least if not stopped since
2003
the catastrophe there has received a
good deal of attention but the actual
implementation of measures to stop the
genocide or to punish the perpetrators
have been insufficiently
taken up I believe that even short of
military intervention by Western armies
there are a number of steps that could
be taken including the imposition of
no-fly zones which would prevent the
Sudanese government and the Janjaweed
militias from getting supplies to the
points where they are attacking the
civilian African populations of Darfur
also the African Union peacekeeping
force which is currently deploying there
needs more support in in helping it
deploy and to deploy under conditions of
security and no-fly zones I think would
help there as well and it is possible
for these measures to be implemented
without even military ground troop
intervention okay so you think there is
hope then I think there is hope there
needed to be a priority given to
stopping the genocide in Darfur and to
bringing the perpetrators to justice and
two of them have currently been indicted
by the International Criminal Court and
there needs to be more pressure on the
Sudanese government perhaps by sanctions
not necessarily by military force but
sanctions could be imposed to the point
where including no-fly zones that they
Sudanese government hands over those to
indicted perpetrators for trial in the
International Criminal Court thank you
very much for sharing some of your
research with us today Thank You Marilyn
for more information about Professor
Kerin in his research and of course his
newest book blood and soil please visit
our website at wwlp.com Akmal and report
be sure to tune in again next week for
another episode of the Macmillan report
made possible through funding from the
Whitney and Betty Macmillan Center for
International and area studies at Yale